[Music]
thank you for joining us on 8 news now
at 11 i'm bryan loftis and metro says
the increase
the number of officers on the strip
after a number of fights and other
problems that happen over labor day
weekend
and some say the problems are continuing
this past weekend metro made
62 arrests over both days and a total of
10 guns were recovered
joe moeller spoke to a woman who says
she was in an altercation
and he's live on the strip tonight with
her story joe
hey there guys leslie woods says she was
walking this trip over near caesar's
palace last night when a group of people
who were on scooters
confronted her now she and other people
we spoke with today say the strip
has a different feeling now another
weekend on the las vegas strip resulted
in more confrontations
being caught on camera highly unusual
like i've never experienced anything
like that
leslie woods says she was walking the
strip near seizures palace with her
boyfriend when a group
rolled up on scooters i think that they
just didn't like that i said watch out
she says they got off those scooters and
an altercation started
she says she called the police but
according to her they never came
i found a police officer and the
incident had just happened
and i said these girls are getting away
on the scooters
and they couldn't leave their post
because donald trump
was in town or coming to town she wasn't
happy with the fight or the police
response
weeks ago on our morning cup of joe
segment the sheriff said there has been
an increase in crime
he says cheaper room rates could be
playing a role labor day
weekend brawls sparked metro to increase
police presence
when las vegas increased room rates and
even filed a lawsuit after a fight took
place there
it's a little bit more scary this time
it's not like it was a couple of years
back
for sure strip visitors notice a
difference just violence honestly
violence is a big thing that
we've both been encountering not
personally but
we've come here for the past few months
and we've seen on the news
many are noticing a lot of these
scooters this is video from august 30th
showing a group of people in the street
i see a lot of people using the uh
the handicapped chairs and they're not
very handicapped there's a lot of people
on scooters i was
mentioning to him the other day or
yesterday actually that there are like
they come in clusters from the
altercation to not getting her 911 call
answered wood says this doesn't make her
want to come back anytime soon
it just didn't feel safe to me
now back out here live woods says she
did file a police report we did reach
out to metro regarding this
we have yet to hear back regarding this
case reporting live here on the strip
joe bowley
8 news now